that's uh I'm going to make the claim
that you should never deal with time
zones manually but as well as that I'll
tell you everything you need to know
about polers and time zones let's get
this started so first of all why you
should never ever deal with time zones
manually I'll try to make a convincing
case uh
Buton I I heard something but didn't
really make out what
okay I'll assume that was
okay and we'll uh
continue where were we right going to
make the case for why you should never
deal with time zones by hand and what
you should do instead that is to say use
software like polers in order to be able
to use polers for time zones I'll then
give a quick crash course on polers and
tell you the basics of what you need to
know to be able to use it for date times
and time zones then finally we'll get to
the real meat of it we'll talk about
pearlers and time zones and finally
we've got uh some minutes split between
an engaging q& day and an awkward
silence it's entirely up to you how long
we make X in this equation every now and
then I'll just uh go from sharing full
screen to checking whether anyone
anyone's written in the chat I'd like
this to be somewhat interactive so if
you have questions you don't need to
wait until the end feel free to make
comments and I'll try to address
them right why should you never deal
with time zones manually so first of all
maybe let's have a show of hands is
anyone here a flat earther do we have
any flat earthers in the house
today not all at once I think I saw a
reaction but oh yeah wow got a thumbs up
nope okay
that's that's the reaction was hoping
for I'm not a flat earther myself not a
flat earther just uh reemphasizing that
in case anyone takes this video out of
context and misquotes me but I do see
the appeal like in particular when it
comes
to time zones it would all be a lot
simpler if we if the Earth was flat so
the the days would always have 24 hours
December the 30th would always come
after December the 29th and scheduling
cross continent meetings would not be
absolutely migrain inducing anyone who
tried this out will know exactly what
I'm talking about so I'm based in the UK
so let's introduce the topic of daylight
savings time in the most British way
possible that is to say with a pub quiz
so suppose you're in oven which is in
the Netherlands and it's midnight on the
26th of March
2023 you then wait 4 hours what time
does your watch show please write your
answer here in the
chat okay got a thumbs up from Ian
hi uh so ad says 27th of March 4 a.m
okay so it's the 20 you're starting on
the 26th of March at midnight and we're
adding four hours so 27th of March would
be quite a lot longer Arthur says 5 a.m.
that's absolutely correct that's the
first correct answer oh hi Shang Shen
also correctly says 5 am
yeah it is indeed the it is indeed 5
a.m. okay I've seen a couple of people
write 27th of March so note that I wrote
plus 4 hours not plus 24 hours and why
is the answer 5 a.m. and not 4: a.m. as
you might have expected and that's
because of a very silly thing called
daylight savings time let's learn about
this thing so there's two components to
it the first is in October where we do
something very silly we are having such
a good time in the night that we don't
want the party to end so when it gets to
the end of 2: a.m. we just go back an
hour and repeat 2 am until 3:00 a.m. so
some day times end up being ambiguous if
it's 1:45 and you're waiting for
somebody and they tell you they'll be
there at 2:15 you have to know there's
no guarantee that they'll be there in
half an hour they might mean one and a
half
hours in March we then do the complete
opposite thing so we're very keen to get
up and go to work so we just skip an
hour completely between 2:00 a.m. and
3:00 a.m. so if somebody tells you of of
an amazing thing that they did at 2:30
a.m. on the 26th of March 2023 in
Amsterdam you have to know they're
making it up this is one way of calling
your friends out on their
stories and you might be thinking this
isn't actually that bad like sure
there's some weirdness but at least it's
consistent distant year on year like as
long as you've got down some set of
rules for when you go back an hour and
when you go forwards an hour how
difficult can it be well pretty
difficult as it turns out let's have a
look at what happened just in
2023 so in Amsterdam on the 26th of
March they skipped an hour meanwhile in
the US they also skipped an hour but two
weeks earlier on the 12th of March uh
most people in Asia and in Africa they I
presume they regard daylight savings
time colonialist so they don't
skip any hours at all but not everywhere
in uh in Morocco they actually repeat an
hour but not at the same time as when
the US and Europe skip an hour they do
it in the week in between on the 19th of
March and then as if this wasn't
confusing enough in Australia on the 1
of April in the Lord how time zone which
is one of Australia's time zones yes
Australia has more than one time zone
they move the the clock they repeat an
hour hour except not the whole hour just
minutes and if I've not convinced you
that this is virtually impossible to get
right doing it by hand well you might be
because you might still be thinking okay
it's it changes from country to country
but I can just have a list of what uh
each country does and then I can map
them all together I can figure it out
well it's not even consistent within
countries so in Samar in the Pacific
they once uh were so Keen to celebrate
New Year's Eve that they switched
straight from the 29th of December to
the 31st of
December if the 30th of December was
your anniversary then tough luck it went
from uh nearly midnight on the 29th of
December to midnight on the 31st of
December because they wanted to switch
time zone they went from a minus 10 UTC
offset to a plus4 UTC offset so don't
expect consistency and I'd like to think
that this proves that you should never
ever deal with time zones manually
QED you don't want to forget about DST
countries doing DST at different times
if at all or countries changing their
time zones right what you should what
should you do instead you should use
poers or some other software that deals
with time zones that's my claim for
today so before we get into the Super
first po crash course let's take a look
at the chat let's see if there's
anything we should respond
to uh clocks jump in March all right my
watch shows for my watch is analog nice
from Jessica um Australia just playing
April Fool's prank on everyone LOL yeah
all right no questions so yeah let's
dive let's go straight into this poos
crash course anyone here familiar with
poas if yes then I'd like to think that
it'll still show you something new a new
way of thinking think of certain things
and if not well it's really just
intended as a basic introduction so
let's let's get this
started so uh data frame is the
fundamental object we're going to be
using within poers it's just a
collection of columns each one of which
has some values which should all be of
the same data type and you can
manipulate them using Expressions uh
wait a second what's an expression an
expression you can think think of it as
a lazy column or slightly more formally
as a function from a data frame to a
series so if I made a function like uh
given a value X double it then what's
the value of this function you don't
know like it doesn't have a value until
you give it an input and similarly B's
Expressions they don't actually have
values until you give them a data frame
so you can create an expression like pl.
call a * 2 Alias B and this will only
take effect once you put it inside the
data frame context most people I think
don't think of Expressions as functions
they just kind of use them and then
develop an intuition for what they
do for example if we start with a
beautiful data frame like this one which
contains one column A with values one
one and two and then we use the with
columns function we can create a new
column called B which is just uh column
A but doubled we can also use inequality
comparisons within expressions and
create a Boolean mask and then we can
use a Boolean mask to only keep certain
rows by using the data frame. filter
function right good stuff but uh I know
you're all very keen to go back to
talking about time zones so let's uh
let's do that but first we need to talk
about data types and I'd like a bit more
audience interaction here going to tell
you about what data types polers
supports and what I'd like you to do is
when I read out your favorite data type
uh either comment here in the chat or
put some Emoji reaction so first of all
let's hear it for the numeric data types
woo yeah this part works better with a
live audience okay got a yay from Ian
and I'm seeing some hearts but can't see
from who presumably we've got lots of
data scientists here in the chat today
all right
Boolean okay I got a couple of thoughts
was wondering if I would get complete
silence for that one if the reaction was
itself going to be Boolean but no
string okay what a single heart I guess
we don't have that many NLP data
scientists um in the chat today what
about
categorical yeah maybe if i' s it with
more enthusiasm nested data types let's
go absolutely bananas for this one I've
seen a talk on YouTube where somebody
says that the primary motivation for
using polers is because of nested data
types they are super powerful the list
one in particular if anyone's doing
Advent of code then the list data type
can make some of the solutions pretty
nifty and then finally my absolute
favorite one the temporal data types
mainly because you can put time zones on
them and I have a niche interest in time
zones let's uh talk about them time
zones aren't the only thing that you can
on the date times they have two
components the time unit and time zone
why do we need
both let's um okay just going to get
back to the chat unless you're in pandas
for the last 20 years okay I can't
remember though what I said when I when
that comment was posted so I'm not
totally sure how to respond to it uh
anyway uh so we've got two components
here to a date time which are the time
unit and a time zone
oh right yeah Ian says that was for
strings in pandas which are slow yes
they are slow but I'll teach you a trick
if you install pyarrow and then in
polers instead of using strings you use
string open square bracket pyarrow
closed square bracket you'd get pyaro
strings which are way better aha see my
talk
tomorrow yeah go to Ian's talk
tomorrow there's quite a few talks here
with pandas 2 and poas and things seems
like a popular topic right so as we were
saying date times got two components
time unit and time zone time unit is
what's the smallest amount of time that
your uh data type can represent and time
zone it can either be none or something
from the time time zone database so none
of these ambiguous abbreviations use a
proper time zone from the time zone
database like Europe London or Africa
Morocco or my favorite Asia catmandu
we'll see later why that's my favorite
why do we need a Time unit let's take a
step back and remember how date times
are represented by computers they're
represented as the amount of time since
the 1st of January 1970 in Universal
Coordinated Time and just to prove to
you that I'm not lying let's look at a
quick example let's make a data frame
with the 30th of November 2023 at noon
and then look at the physical the
underlying physical presentation of that
column we see this very large
unpronouncable number but if we take
that number of microsc and add them to
the 1st of January 1970 we do in indeed
recover our original datetime so there
you go I did not lie
QED why do we need a time zone well time
zones actually change the underlying
integers because the the integer that
backs a date time is the is the amount
of time since the 1st of January 1970 in
Universal Coordinated Time so if you set
a time zone it might actually change
that underlying integer
representation got a little example here
to again prove to you that I'm not lying
and if you compare the integers backing
a time in UTC and a time in Europe
you'll see that the difference is the
number of microseconds in one
hour right sorry a glass of water
right and now for the exciting part of
the talk bers and time zones but first
let's catch up with chat uh nothing to
catch up on fantastic let's go straight
into the exciting stuff polers and time
zones so first of all let's I'd like to
quote the Zen of python which says that
namespaces are one honking great idea
yeah I figured that uh quoting the Z of
python at P dat Global would be okay
when I quoted it at an R conference last
week it didn't get the same
reaction yeah I'm joking of course I
didn't go to an our conference in uh po
namespaces are used to group together
similar functionality so if you start
typing a an expression and then type
dodt you'll get the functions which are
available for temporal data
types if you then continue scrolling
through after a while you might find my
favorite function replace time zone
let's uh take a quick look at what that
does I just wanted to show you this Auto
Complete because pus has excellent type
annotations so if you let your code
editor help you it will really be it
will really make the experience of
coding in polers a lot more pleasurable
than it already is let's take an example
let's start on the 30th of November in
uh Europe let's then localize that to
UTC sorry not localize let's then
replace the time zone with UTC and then
replace the time zone with Asia catmandu
and you'll see that the local time stays
the same but the time zone is
changing you might though be interested
in asking a similar related question
which is if we start with some local
date times in Europe Amsterdam then what
time would those represent but in
different places of the world so if it's
midnight in Europe then uh what time is
it on the same day but in
Nepal and the answer is 4:45 a.m. yeah
that's why Asia Katmandu is my favorite
time zone They are 5 hours and 45
minutes ahead of UTC I think uh I think
the motivation was such that when the
sun was at its highest place it would be
above uh
the the the so when the sun was at its
highest place they wanted it to be
directly on top of Mount kid manaro but
at some at some time of the year and I
wonder what they'll do when tectonic
shift means that's no longer true but by
then you'll all be using poers to deal
with time zones for you so you won't
need to worry about it so when should
you use replace time zone and when
should you use convert time zone convert
time zone answers questions like what
time is it now but in Nepal whereas
replace time zone answers questions like
what if it was this time of day but in
Nepal right we've got some um got a okay
just a smiley here in the chat no
questions to answer so let's
continue let's go back to the public
quiz question I asked you earlier so if
it's the 26th of March in oven which is
in the
Netherlands in um yeah it's midnight 26
of March 2023 what time is it four hours
later and the answer is use polers so
let's see how you could do that you're
going to want to use a method called dt.
offset by offset by can take different
kinds of durations we've got calendar
durations like day week month and uh so
on and fixed durations like hour minute
second so here we'll want to use four
hours so we'll just write dt. offset by
4H and you'll see that indeed we do get
the correct answer which several people
gave earlier during the first pub quiz
which was 5 a.m. but now we got the same
answer with polers so we're
happy I just want
to include a word of caution which is
that you might naively be thinking that
1D and 24h are exactly the same thing
and this is where we come to the
difference between a calendar duration
and a fixed duration so 24 hours that
literally means 24 hours it's
unambiguous 24 hours whereas 1D means
One calendar day so it's same time but
on the next day if we start the 2 on the
29th of October 2023 in Amsterdam and we
add one day we get to the 30th of
October whereas if we had 24 hours we
get to 11 p.m on the same day because
that's when they moved the clocks back
so use whichever one is more appropriate
for your situation I'd be willing to bet
that most of the time what you really
want is one calendar day rather than 24
hours but it's good to be aware of the
difference now whenever I give a talk
about time zones there's always some
smarty pants who tells me that we don't
need time zones we can just do
everything in
UTC so let's uh dispel
that suppose that we've got some date
times in a European Time Zone and some
sales for each hour and our boss asks us
how many sales did we make in total each
day so if if we were to just look at
this we would see okay on the the 29th
of November looks like we've got one 2 3
four five sales and on the 30th of
November we've got one sale so we give
them that answer correctly however if we
tried to First convert to UTC then the
date boundaries would have shifted so on
the 28th of November we would have had
one sale 29th of November four sales and
30th of November one sale if our boss
had asked us why we'd reported that
there was one sale on a date that they
didn't even give us data for and we
reply well somebody on Reddit told me to
convert to UTC we won't seem so
smart the other issue with converting to
UTC is that in UTC days always have 24
hours but we've seen that in your local
time zone a day might have 25 hours 23
hours or if you're in Australia 24 and a
half hours or 23 and
half all of the examples I've shown you
so far they've assumed that you had a
data
frame which already had some date times
in it but as we all know the world runs
on csbs which don't preserve data types
so how do we read data from a CSV into
poers especially if it's time zone
aware now a secret tip I'd like to show
you is to use the argument trass dates
if your date if your date times are
stored in a common format then polers
will automatically infer it for you and
pass your data as uh as you've requested
as a date time this is more efficient
than first reading a CSV with strings
and then later
converting if your string values contain
UTC offsets then what polus does is it
converts everything to UTC like Arrow
does uh Pi Arrow at least so in this
example we've got some offsets like UTC
plus 2 UTC plus one and so on and but
when polus passes it it doesn't preserve
them it converts everything to
UTC if you know that your dates your
date strings correspond to some local
time zone then it's up to you to set it
as one of the D types so we could set
here datetime having a dtype of pl.
dtime microsc and Europe Amsterdam time
zone and then we'll get what look like
some local Day times each at midnight in
Amsterdam and you might be wondering why
why can't poers do this for you and the
answer is it just doesn't know let's
have another pub quiz suppose it's the
29th of October 2023 at midnight 2 hours
ahead of UDC 24 hours later what time is
it and I'll spoil the answer here for
you it's you don't know so uh in if
you're in oven it would be 11 p.m. on
the same day but if you are in Botswana
then it would be the 30th of October on
the next day so poas isn't going to
guess for you where you're where you are
it's it's up to you to set the time zone
that your date strings correspond
to so in confusion what have we talked
about today we've talked about how you
should never ever deal with time zones
manually because there's just too much
complexity around daylight savings time
time zone changes and CrossCountry
comparisons we then did AP Poo's crash
course learned a bit how to work with
date times time zones and then finally
we talked about time zones in poers we
learned about the difference between one
day which is one calendar day and 24h
which is 24 hours we then looked at the
at the difference between replace time
zone and convert time zone for changing
between time zones and when you would
use one rather than the other and then
finally we learned that passing offset
aware strings results in
UTC time zone and it's up to you to set
the time zone that you know that your
data corresponds to now please go out
and convert some time zones I do offer
some polus training I yeah get in
contact with me or with my employer
quanite labs and we can figure something
out thanks for your attention and let's
open up the floor to some questions I
can see some clapping emojis and some
heart emojis thank you everybody for
your support you absolutely wonderful so
Ian asks any gotas to be aware for users
of pandas with time zone handling so
pandas uh the time zones are technically
incorrect after
2038 because it needs to update how it's
uh doing them so if you're using data
that's after 2038 then uh for now I'd
suggest using polers and not using
pandas uh otherwise use whichever you're
already using in your application or
whichever one you're more um familiar
with uh other than that anything
yeah other than that I'm not aware of
any
gotas uh they should work quite
similarly uh so Lucas asks what date
datetime features does polers not yet
offer so one that comes to mind is
interpolating values based on a column
of date times in pandas if your date
times are the index you can easily
interpolate with I think it's like
series. interpolate method equals index
polus doesn't yet support that
but somebody did write on the Discord
today that they were planning to work on
that so hopefully we'll have this
relatively
soon and that leads me to that leads me
on to the topic of the Discord the pol's
Discord is really active and lots of fun
so if you're not in it already I'd
suggest you head on over to the poers
readby and join the Discord and say
hello
there Ian says on note for others if you
use today time in po you get nicer pass
error message messages is more useful
than if you do the same in uh pandas
okay well that's probably um a damning
indictment on myself because I've done a
lot of the work in h to dat time in
pandas so I'll thanks Ian I'll take this
as a to-do for what I should um yeah for
what I should do in in pandas thanks
okay Shang asks what why poers for
handling time zones what's stopping FR
yeah so uh Shang I think your question
is about why is Po was uh correct after
2038 but uh pandas Isn't So pandas for
time zones uses pytz whereas poas for
time zones is deferring everything to a
rust Library called kronoz and there's a
limitation in uh
pytz uh regarding that but there is an
issue about switching from pytz to Zone
info in pandas there it's just yeah lots
of Legacy code to update lots of things
to do and relatively little funding so
yeah that's just the reality of Open
Source Ian says no critique just an
observation yes I uh yeah n taken I toor
I didn't mean that in the sense of I'm
offended more like thanks for bringing
that up uh this is a
too uh okay Moon would you mention again
when one would use convert time zone
versus replace time zone so convert time
zone you've got some local datetime and
you want to know what local daytime that
would be somewhere else whereas replace
time zone is more like you've got some
local date time and you just want to
make that same local date time but in a
different place if you look at the if
you look them up in the docs there's
examples on of both I think most poers
doc strings have
examples uh Luca could you elaborate
more on the example of sales why should
I not run any logic in UTC so I'd
suggest storing your date times in UTC
but once you need to do logic that is
above the hourly level so anything
you're doing at the daily level then the
the the boundaries between dates changes
according to your time zone so if if
you're in a time zone which is exactly
the same as UTC and does not observe
Daylight Savings time then by all means
do all your logic in UTC but if you're
If You observe Daylight Savings Time
like uh we do in UK Europe uh United
States lots of places then doing
everything in UTC means that sometimes
your date boundaries are going to be
like from 11:00 p.m. the previous day to
11:00 p.m. on this day that might not be
what you want so storage UTC is good
logic to local yeah that's right cool I
think we might be at uh time I can't
remember if it was 30 minutes including
questions uh